Mr Speaker can I join your tribute to
John and wish him all the West on behalf
of the house and join the prime minister
in his comments about the Holocaust
Memorial I'd also like to wish Muslims
across the country a happy Eid and Mr
Speaker last week the labor party lost
Margaret Madonna
our first female General Secretary and a
Trailblazer in every sense of the word
Margaret provided guidance leadership
and loyal friendship to so many in the
labor movement and it wasn't long after
I started in this job that Margaret was
at my door and I will be forever
grateful for the advice and support that
she gave me we will all miss her
terribly
Mr Speaker his party spent thousands of
pounds on adverts attacking plans to
build three hundred thousand new homes a
year at the same time his housing
Minister says it's Tory party policy to
build 300 000 new homes a year
so is he four building three hundred
thousand new homes a year or against it
prime minister well Mr Speaker I can't
just remind all the gentlemen of our
record uh since being in office 2.2
foreign
2.2 million additional homes Mr Speaker
housing starts double the number we
inherited from the labor party more
homes meeting the decent home standards
housing Supply up 10 in the last year
that we have figures for and into in the
last year we had figures so we also saw
a 20-year high in the number of
first-time buyers Mr Speaker that's a
conservative government delivering for
this country
Mr Speaker it wasn't a difficult
question
so can you point to a single person in
housing in construction anywhere who
thinks he'll actually hit his Target of
300 000 new homes a year anyone anyone
prime minister Mr Speaker the record is
that in the last three years we've
delivered almost record numbers of New
Home Building and every one of those
years but a bit Mr Speaker talks about
Target so let's be clear I promise to
put local people in control of new
housing I delivered on that policy
within weeks of becoming prime minister
but I am confused from The Honorable
gentleman because first the shadow
community and housing secretary said
communities should have control but then
he then said we should get the targets
back and disempower local people I do
want to give him some advice I don't
think it's local people that are the
problem it's a labor party policy
Mr Speaker presumably if he could have
identified a single person who thought
he'd hit his Target he would have told
us
and there you have the problem one
minute he says he's for building new
houses the next he's campaigning against
them and the truth is far from
delivering since he crumbled to his back
benches and scrapped mandatory targets
house building has collapsed he knows it
they know it and every expert is telling
me why didn't just admit it he's not
going to get anywhere near his Target is
he no I'm in
building and
it's in the on the Green Belt but
unfortunately for him it's good that he
agrees that he does believe that now but
unfortunately for him the shadow Deputy
Prime Minister the shadow Minister for
women the shadow Health Justice defense
business Northern Ireland and Scotland
ministers are all United against more
health building in their areas Mr
I would say to them though they
they worry too much because he's never
actually kept a promise he's made
[Applause]
[Music]
tell from his aunt said not answering
his body language he's actually given up
he's given up
and his failure isn't just shattering
the dream of those who desperately want
to own their own home it's also hitting
those who already have a mortgage
because of their economic chaos mortgage
holders will be 2 900 pounds a year
poorer
how can they ever look the British
people in the eye again and claim to be
the party of home ownership
prime minister Mr Mr Speaker I don't I
don't think he's noticed that his shadow
housing secretary doesn't actually agree
with his new policy of concreting over
the green belt Mr Speaker she's been
campaigning against developments in her
own constituency she said she wanted to
prevent urban sprawl and provide Green
Space for local people I think that's
quite sensible but it's classic labor Mr
Speaker saying one thing here doing
another thing elsewhere you simply can't
trust a word they say
at least he isn't claiming they are the
party of home ownership anymore because
we are
Mr Speaker
enough
Mr Speaker the Prime Minister the Prime
Minister says he's a hundred percent on
it but his definition of a hundred
percent on it is to gently ask the banks
to do the right thing he's softly softly
approach refusing to put mandatory
measures in place risk leaving a million
households without support
how many will have to lose their homes
Before He'll stand up for the people his
party have pushed into economic misery
[Applause]
Mr Speaker if at the vast majority of
the mortgage Market is now covered
that the chances brought in that is
delivering practical help to mortgage
holders allowing them to extend their
terms switch to interest-only mortgage
and actually saving them hundreds of
pounds a month so instead of scaring
them actually there is now practical
support in place but it's right that he
raised at home ownership Mr Speaker
that's why we on this side of the house
introduce a 95 mortgage guarantee scheme
it's why we introduced the first homes
and shared ownership schemes to get
people onto the housing ladder and
crucially Mr Speaker it's why we cut
stamp Duty so now what we've seen is the
highest number of first-time buyers in
20 years Mr Speaker that is twice the
number that the labor party ever managed
thank you
Mr Speaker it's it's sort of housing
crisis what crisis with this prime
minister he must be the only person in
the country who thinks that enough
houses have been built in the last 13
years and whether it's those dreams of
getting the keys to their first home or
those already with mortgages the
Ambitions of families across the country
have been crushed by his failure Tory
government house building at its lowest
rate since the war because he can't
stand up to his own party a Tory
mortgage bombshell because they crashed
the economy Millions left without
support because he won't make lenders
put Families First rather than lecturing
the rest of the country and holding
their nerve why doesn't he try and
locate his
[Applause]
time to understand the detail of what
we're doing so again I I I'm happy to
I'm happy I'm happy to explain it again
Mr Speaker because it's right that we
provide support for mortgage owners
which is why we improve the generosity
of the support for mortgage interest
scheme it's why we've introduced the new
mortgage Charter which by the way goes
much more farther than the labor party
policy on protecting mortgage holders
does on house building we're proud to
protect the green belt and invest
Millions more in developing Brownfield
sites that Mr Speaker the simple truth
is that's what I said I would do and
that's what we've delivered and that is
the difference between us I deliver what
I promise he just breaks hands
foreign